[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
youtube oh this year
i'll miss hosting that lunch we did with
fans
every year at gamescom or the impromptu
meets and greets we would do
uh at gamescom with our studio teams
going out for coffee and answering a
especially during difficult times
i love the family feeling that our
gaming community
aaron green
of the world today my man so many people
gaming is now the primary way that many
of us stay connected it is our primary
social way to connect with our friends
no matter where they are
and that's why i'm excited to highlight
our especially our german and
dude what's going on 79. i know you
liked that destiny stream earlier with
them through xbox yeah
because whether you're there and
let me know how these are connected the
levels are for the stream it compares to
our voices
everyone at team xbox
of the gamescom gaming community and
fans thank you for the memories
thank you for joining us here at 2021
xbox gamescom stream
the games come the dungeons
is
all the panels
he
hello
oh
but if you're into the newest tech like
the brand new xbox
man i love
go check it out
is
um
oh they jumping in man they don't care
yeah peggy 18
you guys can't hear me yeah you
know they say i can hear you they saying
you're drinking clothes
right right simulator like sam for the
switch
let's see your final two chances
xbox everybody put your bayonets up
we've got so many great game updates to
share with you today we're talking age
of empires 4 psychonauts 2 and my
personal favorite microsoft flight
simulator later on we'll take an
extensive look at forza horizon 5.
there's so much going into this and
playground games vision of mexico is
like
the graphics
look at the cover car for the game paris
[Music]
pass
right
game design
and this is
animation
we can't wait until december 7th to
finally give you dying light to stay
human the game we have been working on
really hard for the last few years for
you we're hoping the gameplay video
you're about to watch will give you a
full taste of parkour and combat systems
waiting for you in the game and we are
just about to enter the city fighting
our way through its brutal and dangerous
rights
there are plenty of things you can use
to your advantage so watch closely look
for a special combat entertainment
oh
[Applause]
the virus started it boy but it was the
people who made the world the way it is
everybody get their bags together so you
can just put the knees inside the bags
they told me they had a vision i want
everyone to reach under your chair
this is the bag right there
many different ones yeah i can't wait
for this game
that looked like cognito right when he
got out of the gym yeah
oh that was awesome
[Music]
they say they say at the end parkour
exclusive on xbox series you can't
parkour
[Music]
let's check and see
also available in that s2 it's like
something off wasteland yeah oh my
mouse people
no no no no no no no no please no no not
like this
is a series of small gestures
the parachute we got
[Music]
jumped off his back slamming on the
floor
we'll
oh
one very important for the plot of dying
lights too
are we going to see forge today
you and your team
so much for watching
well all you need is a few thousands of
information cooperation with
professional traces mock-up sessions
whose face and moves player will see in
the game by the way
no yes right and we've got twice the
number of parkour moves compared to the
first game and we are showing some of
them in this trailer the vault kicks
being the most important to me
personally it brings a whole new
building
together
further attacks for example by
rebounding from their bodies jumping of
them
i think we captured the movement
i can't wait for them to try it out and
tell for themselves how much they loved
it
it's definitely going to be useful the
city's buildings are higher than
anything we have done before improving
its verticality players will need to
find a way to reach those tall
skyscrapers and other challenging
species
some helpers around play with park
glider which can support players in both
parkouring and combat exactly and it's
gonna do great especially in fights
against humans which are more frequent
and important than in dying light 1.
it's been over 20 years since the events
from the first game so people adjusted
they are much bolder now at least during
the day and they are more vicious too
the lala solutions
summary of this discussion
pre-order dying glide 2 and explore its
vast complex world on december 7th
thanks david thank you it's gonna have
power
the medic stupid he's out rather see
campaign co-op
that is day one
all right for the first time
history of the franchise microsoft
flight simulator launched on a home
console with the release on xbox series
x and s last month reviewers and gamers
alike were blown away by how well the
stunning visuals and the depth of the
simulation translated to the console and
that's why i'm extremely honored
microsoft flight simulator you're new
into the stream york thank you for being
here the last time we met was at the
xbox showcase and it was getting ready
to come out on consoles how did that go
it went great as you said the reaction
to the xbox contract launch was it was
really just amazing
both from xbox gamers and from the press
they've been so gracious with their
feedback i don't know if you know but
the flight simulator is one of the
highest rated games on xbox this year
which i think is just great validation
we do know that the trans that's the
translation of the simulations to the
console
has really worked well
our usage numbers are through the roof
we are absolutely shattering franchise
records i can tell you there's never
been more people playing flight
simulator than right now so it's an
awesome time
that is awesome congratulations on the
launch really what can you see that uh
oh he bringing the shades back out he
breaking it back out he ready for the
top gun
i want to go to the danger zone
what's going on with top gun there's so
much going on paris um so you and i
talked about top gun maverick earlier
the fans are super excited they saw the
f-18 they can't wait to start flying
and uh as you know it comes out later
this year it's free dlc alongside the
movie
but as the movie is still under wraps
and so are we so i can still not tell
you that much about what are you doing
in conjunction with movies there's so
much else going on even before maverick
so um um we are continuing to do our
monthly big releases that we've been
doing for a long time and next month on
september 7th
we are launching
world updates
and um
at the beginning of the show if you
remember there was a little red plane
flying into cologne but we did that
because world update 6 updates that
region the region of gamescom so germany
austria and switzerland and what that
means to us is we have new aerial and
satellite images we have a new elevation
map that helps us with the mountains so
the alps actually look awesome now um we
have new 3d cities like frankfurt
in germany
in switzerland um
[Music]
and we also added airports we did blue
back and forth in germany
that's right
sort of tours of the country about all
the awesomeness
the beauty of this weekend
and this this is
going to review wow
i'm so happy
to be able to announce the date yeah i
just watched dale's video uh right now
so he talked about he said you know that
is really incredible all the different
regions and everything that you're gonna
put into the game and the the way that
you're gonna be able to actually
highlight those
yeah i think it's it's it's really cool
but you know for us it's actually not
just the region and the visuals we are
we
are
we talked a lot when you when you study
aviation when you love aviation like we
do um you actually realize that a lot of
regions of earth have a very special
relationship with flying with aviation
sometimes
why do we not use these world updates to
celebrate the plans
so we're announcing a new series it's we
call them local legends and think about
that as planes that are
locally well known like in that region
but outside in the world not so much and
but why not use the world updates to
highlight this to bring these awesome
machines to a worldwide audience so for
world update six we picked uh a
journalist from the 1930s philly
perfect
i just want to make sure that this is
lovingly
so and you
and we think of us as sort of a digital
digital preservation so we really want
to get these planes to an extreme level
of detail we're going out of our way to
really go
deep so we're doing a full scan we'll
take full scans of the outside and the
inside as detailed as one millimeter so
really which is as good as you can as
i'm getting ready to do this and then
we're working with for the junkers we
worked with band junkers who is the
grandson of the original creator of the
plane hugo junckers and he's helping us
he had a ton of insight and materials
then we worked with an organization that
is preserving one of the last surviving
examples
he lets us know like is the cockpit
right and the sounds right does it feel
right in the air um so we're having a
blast working with these ways to really
bring these to celebrate this plan to
bring them back to life so this is
almost like you're creating like a
digital museum for aviation inside
microsoft flight simulator yeah i mean
it's basically that it's a museum that
reliable planes so we're working with um
40 museums it's a great thing this is
one of the funnest parts of the job
so they can do something with that just
and it's a great collaboration
looking back in the history of aviation
we're also looking towards the future so
i have another announcement we are
working with a fascinating german
company called volocopter yeah and then
yeah
to make sure
inside of microsoft flight simulator is
there anything else you want to share uh
yeah there's one more thing um yeah we
are i'm so happy to announce that we've
partnered with rahra
that's the reno air racing association
and they every year they put on
something called
the steel national
traffic projects and we're bringing this
to flight simulator so it's
race
speed
we're going to the danger
[Music]
[Music]
in
[Music]
that's the rhino effect
a little bit on that rahra
i wonder how long it's gonna take them
before they start having you race people
oh nevermind
it's it coming soon
that game is impressive
play it day one pc castle gate pass
let's get it you know i like going fast
you know i love being in the danger zone
when is this coming out
man these these planes they fly 500
miles faster than 500 miles an hour
on microsoft
i mean
yo yeah
[Laughter]
um this is also the first time this is a
game this year yeah we got to look for
the perspective of this year so they'll
be talking about a lot of that stuff
that we're getting a competitive
multiplayer is coming to microsoft
flights
competitive multiplayer that would
definitely test your pilots
when is it coming out we are this is
coming out this fall so it's right
around the corner that's a rob roberto
that is fantastic and you know i have
the need
a little bit
that's a good announcement
competitive in some of these air races a
lot of you got you covered
just to play that competitive
if going fast on the ground is for your
speed keep an eye out for an extended
look at forza horizon 5. later on in the
stream we'll also talk with wasteland
3's game director about the game
dlc
if you're an xbox game pass subscriber
we have some great news for you
uh-oh
j-pad section
i like this i like this
it's a humble game
no i think they just got deal with them
i like that right midnight
[Music]
oh okay what up now
what up now it looks easy they're
killing it with the indies y'all what up
man yo somebody said rah-rah day one of
them games yo y'all stupid
that's a rah-rah tracy
do they have a simulation of unpacking
is that what happened
fill it up with the ending
[Applause]
[Music]
let's talk about what's coming up we're
talking age of empires four the game's
creative director and we're gonna see
what's next for us yes
but now we've got a new roguelike retro
shooter that in grand retro fashion
sends you plundering through shifting
dungeons to defeat a mysterious eldritch
chair let's dive into the pit
into the pit
where's this
sure looks nice
[Music]
it's a roguelike
oh
it's doom like
yeah with sorcery it's like doom and
like bio shots yeah that's what i love
right here
this is it put fire on one hand
it's very very doomed fish
mode here
yo wait through the heads up we're
throwing up gigs what are we doing
what's going on
rock man that's rocking that's rock out
man yeah they're throwing up signs
though oh no no that was your lack of
mother music i'm sorry
look at it we we must educate them
here he's calling that gangster listen
i don't know if they want to be
promoting that culture
and we've also shown a little bit of our
campaigns
right through uh
in age of empires 4 that we're kind of
bringing history of life that we haven't
talked about yet see you do this to me
you put me in suspense i want to know
more so let's go with it let's hear more
okay wait you get one moment of
suspense okay that's enough so um what
we've brought today is um we have these
wonderful little videos that we've
created that are interspersed amongst
the campaign and they're about three to
five minutes each
and um
we have over an hour of them total and
they're called on histories and what
they are is a great way to like deep
dive on certain fun subjects
from the cultures we're representing and
just from medieval history
you've actually brought one of those
here for the very first time
the segment on one of the most popular
units from age of empires franchise and
a fan favorite the trebuchet excellent
well this should be let's see
break my [ __ ]
they represent
is
is
and by launching the projectile from a
sling it teaches you
man they're giving us a fix this class
trebuchets were carefully aimed unless
they put someone on that just
educate us sir that would tribute not in
the age of empires
i mean i think we've all seen troy
what that does
but like this is we're getting into the
history channel
we have been playing chivalry
150 kilograms that's the weight of two
men but this is something they added to
the game that's all i would like i would
like to see it in the game though let's
hope let's go let's hope they don't kill
some poor soul with this
thing anything to
he said i just got here why are the
lords reaching oh i come with 28.
yes
i don't care because that is awesome
he said the lords are reacting to the
history channel yeah
that kind of was the history
and you could say that about any subject
really right but i think the great thing
is is when you have someone that's so
enthusiastic and passionate about
history it really comes across and we
wanted to be that kind of team and i
hope his mouth and keyboard and um yes
there's a phrase called humanized
history
trying to do which is we try to like
connect past
the way you can see that um
you can imagine for media and um they
travel to all of these locations in all
these different countries to meet these
subject matter experts and get all of
this great footage from how things
really worked and how things were made
and
it's been delightful
you know
get all these and finally start showing
the duke of brooklyn i love it
you also of course
you've got
anything else that you can tell us fans
about what we can expect looking forward
to any favorites you got coming up oh
well favorites oh man well um i think my
personal favorite is one called medieval
surgery and i'm gonna let your
imagination go with what we might show
and what we might talk about in that one
yeah um but the thing i love about them
is that they
you know we've got ones on warfare
building and like how they kept flaming
arrows
[Laughter]
that's them because we good yeah no
that's not us oh okay okay i paid i paid
my internet
this is what they call blackout move oh
man let's go oh xbox this is not good
[Music]
oh yeah everything okay it's not just us
everybody said rip rip black scream
someone said germany's under attack no
what happened
all the playstation fans got together
indian style knees back together
this never happens only twitch is down
all right so k asante is on youtube up
youtube y'all
let me know we'll make we'll make it on
the fly audible if we got to you know
if twitch ain't can't do you know what
i'm saying twitch can't do yes xbox the
xbox is still up on okay so twitch hurry
up go to youtube all right we got you we
got you oh man we missed a lot
go to the official oh yeah official yeah
yeah
yeah okay okay
wow that's a few things but you're
having fun and oh we missed
that middle ground
every time we've tried the show we've
shown the campaigns
on
history the great thing is
yeah sorry y'all together have just been
like wow this is great and it's so
different and kind of cool and
refreshing
so uh and i love to watch
silence
11 a.m pacific time yo zero say always
missing how to load and use the canon
fellas
so much for joining us here always a
pleasure kate always a pleasure age of
empires 4 looks fantastic so i cannot
wait october 28th neither should you now
we have tons coming up here today
including a new update for state of
decay 2 and an extended look at forza
horizon 5 with our friends at playground
games but now let's catch up with perry
who's gone from flying the skies and
microsoft bites him to a different kind
of cloud
she called them potty that's right kate
xbox cloud gaming is already available
on windows pcs mobile phones and tablets
and now it's coming to xbox consoles the
future with cloud gaming sounds bright
no waiting to install no running out of
hard drive space no waiting to patch and
no buying a new console just to play
with your friends see how the vision of
cloud gaming will bring people together
without barriers much love
cloud and when i think about gaming
those two things together to me really
show you the future where you can pick
up something and you can play it
anywhere and you could do it quickly
[Music]
[Music]
that's pretty great i mean this is
that's pretty awesome this actually
looks so good
games are large and you want to keep the
ones that you know you love on your hard
drive xbox cloud gaming is about being
able to discover the new ones right away
it's super exciting that for our game
pass ultimate members they will get to
experience xbox cloud gaming on whatever
console they have cloud gaming is really
about looking at how
to take from railroads i know me in
particular sometimes i just got 20 330
people hit that like button
let's get that above 200
the process itself to get into cloud
gaming feels like you're playing on
console right you go you finally i agree
it's so easy nowadays you can pick
up if my friends have titles that i
don't have yet i can just wait for them
to send me an invite and it makes
content just so much more accessible
i don't think people realize the power i
really love the flexibility that's
awesome
everything that xbox is doing right now
is just getting rid of the limits of
having to be on a specific platform or a
specific console play on pc and mobile
and now i think um
there's so much opportunity when it
comes to thinking about how we can make
content more readily available and let
people play oh it's an option to hold
consoles sign me up okay
that's what it is that's the mobile
aspect this is the console level okay i
was like this one's already out
got it because
you'll be able to play star field on
your xbox one so the bass xbox oh
everybody could do okay that's actually
good though that's actually good
for the console
august nine games
of the free optimize update for
hellblade serial sacrifice on the xbox
series s and x with beautiful enriched
visuals thanks to the addition of ray
tracing and if you know the material
alongside performance updates this is
the perfect opportunity to relive
cinewa's journey or experience it for
the first time and if you haven't played
this do yourself a favor
grab a pair of headphones and immerse
yourself into this world
speaking of unique experiences on game
pass the xbox plays team will be yeah
can play series actually this time
and the big con that's huge they're also
talking with developers from halo the
master chiefs collection was horizon
five
in
so far and
the cult of the holy detonation we gotta
get back on that
my thing is like
i don't mind seeing your expansions and
stuff because i know
they've got a lot of stuff
see the pandemic
with new patches bug fixes and added
features like fine wine wasteland 3 just
gets better with age to really savor the
game's bouquet we're talking with in
exile game director david rogers david
thank you for joining us thanks so much
for a very long time so can you kind of
talk about that journey yeah our dad
talk about it on ielts full time
we've
well congratulations on everything that
you've been doing with wastelands
man i can get some shades
you can do that
now talk about that little bit tell tell
me what's going to go into this dlp what
what should we be excited about
right so you've heard of uh cheyenne
mountain right for those who haven't
cheyenne mountain is this uh top-secret
military complex buried deep in the
heart of cheyenne mountain in the middle
of colorado it's designed to outlast a
nuclear winter yeah
old friend calls you and says hey i need
your help securing the secret the
military base and all the secrets within
and as soon as you get there
you fight
battling over supremacy trying to take
control of the holy detonation which is
team how generous
that sounds a lot cooler than some of
the cults i may have joined in the past
but
this is typical wasteland fashion we're
really busy
donation cheyenne mountain and
ultimately all of colorado this is
really your game to craft and mold
that's awesome so the last expansion was
the battle of steel town right you had
giant robots and things like that so you
know what what are you gonna do do to
actually top something like that from
the last week
right so we wanted
returning players to find something that
they could never find in another version
like in previous versions of wasteland
3. and so we built this as a wasteland
dungeon you want to get into that in
there you find this awesome mix of
mystery exploration you're meeting these
crazy cultists who have been lost in
this three war time capsule and
something like that
you it's no longer you're like huddling
in a corner throwing down turrets just
going on murderous rampages it's not
about killing it's about getting the job
done and so now you went over the
railroad section including we send you
on twitter
you're in there breaking into prisons
rescuing pows you're disrupting these
high-tech cultist rituals you are
splitting your fire team and
coordinating like you never have had to
before like everyone on your team has a
job i really think this is going to take
a little silly
right
what are some of the weird characters we
can expect in some of the story
encounters we will see in in the game
yeah with this with cult of the holy
detonation we really got to cut our devs
loose and just let them be creative and
fun and simple
modus operando
how are we doing
afterwards because we want to make
something that entertains us and then we
know if we're having fun our fans are
going to have fun along with us and so
we got to explore like really letting
you get deep into this like weird
radiation cult and let you interact with
them and talk with them um and tell
stories and like maybe even join them
yeah um and so like for instance one of
the characters you meet one of the first
cultists you meet is this slathering
beast he's got like claws into fangs and
spikes jutting out
but he's like the nicest guy in cheyenne
see that energy you gotta
and like and another one of my favorites
is the produce
if uh if you took like 20 cultists and
you like melted them into a big pile
kind of like i would do this with like a
magnifying glass like melt like army
guys and like gi joes into a big pile
and he's wet and sloppy and gross and
he's hard to understand and he needs a
translator supposedly and but he's like
your number one fan and getting to build
like this totally out there wild extreme
character was a ton of fun to write for
it's a ton of fun to like explore like
what makes this cult
and he's an absolute blast
even some of the weapons
themes that let us jack knife between
dark and serious and like
funny which is the line that wasteland
really loves to ride like
a lot of too early
but you know
the way slanted
what would you suggest for new players
wanting to get into this and like i said
at the top like wasteland is like the
best version of itself right now because
of all the work we put in over into it
and so you can get the whole thing with
the colorado collection okay that's the
base game plus cult of the holy
detonation and battle of steel town all
for a discount or if you have game pass
you already have wasteland three just
download it and play it and then you can
get both expansions with the expansion
pass
that is awesome now to kind of recap so
for the record dlc we have to pay you
know
but people think that dlc
because they gave the game
things that are going to be it was
originally supposed to come in all of it
please remind them the first couple they
did it
when can you pick up this right this
work of passion it comes out on october
5th october 3rd
that is awesome so this is the cult of
the holy debt cult of the holy day
detonation coming october 5th
thank you so much
in the three years since its launch sea
of thieves has played host to some
incredible crossovers including ships
inspired by games like battletoads state
of decay
halo and more today we're excited to
announce a brand new special event that
will award players in all new ships
as a part of the latest wild crossover
heading to sea of thieves better yet
this event begins tomorrow
so get ready to make some mayhem and
let's get our first look at this very
special she read his eyes off
[Music]
oh look at the dancers come on
no slave dancers
[Music]
uh really cool to be a part of this all
digital gamescom event and we were
thinking what's the best way to kind of
celebrate gamescom it was crazy we just
got to see these
things that you've just seen
really cool that's inspired by
boardlands
here we go give all of our players a
chance it
again
so it's been really cool to work with
the board last night
i want to point out there was not
million people playing at
billion
and i think that's it from me so as
always i will see you on the season
we're wasting all that money on that
pirate band
that's not pulling
big team battle that's all you're going
to get
there we go this is not different for
that guys state of decay looking like
right
yeah
okay what are we doing
it's always good dangerous world
but now
it's hope
that brings us back together
there's hope that brings us back to the
concert every year
[Music]
jesse jackson version of old edition
oh there you go ricardi salute
you know he in the game of the model
right oh that's what's up
[Music]
this is how they keep people in game
pads september 1st
that along with new games along with
double a uh indeed well just like
zombies base game free
and we have a guest to walk us through
this undead update please join me in
welcoming undead labs director of
communications wander russell oh
remember her hello i'm great it's great
to be here
homecoming update releasing on september
1st we are very excited to get this into
players
indeed so let's talk about the
homecoming update uh obviously we are
coming back to trumbull valley we were
there for heartland the upstate back in
2019. i didn't know exactly what i'm
talking about
okay
start new communities there
start exploring everything that the new
map passes let me stop nothing happened
y'all nothing happened
to heartland
yeah exactly right so
the events in heartland
kind of play out i told you i knew that
he's in trouble valley so we think
continued into heartland and now that's
going to be what has happened since then
and what storylines might be coming to a
close
so there is a lot for players to
discover a lot of environmental
storytelling to find and you know things
have changed so this isn't the trumbull
valley that players might remember so
that's going to be exciting interesting
well any time you expand something like
trumbull valley you just have to have a
juggernaut of content pun intended uh
talking a little bit about what some of
those things are the players can get in
on here now in the expanded trumbull
valley yes a ton of new content in fact
we're doing something unique with the
jungle valley map there are items there
that you can only find on that map and
nowhere else in the game including 12
new hats and outfits so the bases
are going to be on that map right we've
got six new bases two new achievements
for achievement hunters yes and on top
of that we are adding the game's 12th
bounty pack so that will
a juggernaut amount of content and i
don't care who sees the second
it's absolutely an integral part to this
entire franchise and state of decay
being on xbox game pass how has that
impacted the community how has that
impacted the game talk to me about those
it's been fantastic and you know we have
an amazing community we love them so
much in fact one of the reasons we're
doing trouble valley as a map is because
it was one of the most requested
features from the community which also
makes it very exciting for us to be able
to say
ah we did it you get it uh and we have a
major milestone that we're celebrating
state of decay 2
has 10 million lifetime players
10 million lifetimes hang your hat on
that i absolutely love that really
grateful incredible amazing news
congratulations to you and the entire
team at undead labs man fantastic work
uh well speaking of xbox game pass let's
give me the deets one more time when it
comes to the update so the update
releases september 1st it's a free
update for all state of decay 2 owners
xbox game pass
happy homecoming so homecoming is free
thank you wonder very much my pleasure
now we move from trumbull valley to the
lost valley of akria this mystical
location trades zombies for ancient
warrior clans forgotten temples of long
dead god kings and a healthy dose of
hack and slash all this awaits in
straight blade you know the chat you're
so messy with attitude
[Applause]
what up
boys
oh
you discover the mystical lost valley of
a crea a world which ranges from
overgrown temple ruins to frozen caves
and winding canyons a game world that
changes based on your victories and
plenty of dues to stab in combat
you even get a fuzzy little pal to help
you out between the epic fights and this
small guy there's clearly a lot going on
here so let's hear more from point blank
games about straight blade straight
hello everybody i'm lennon kaush game
director at point playing games and
today i will show you straight blade
you look like this is an action rpg
as well
are the two key elements of our game
let's dive into the combat first surely
you had a big ass
system
strategic anticipation of enemy attacks
is the high noon of skill-based melee
movie
it
weapon combat to achieve that
fluid readable animations
you can choose from multiple categories
well it's not that it's too colorful no
let's take a look at the different
actually korea's colorful world ranges
from overwatch
to frozen caves
together with your companion
the deepest corners of an ever-changing
world wrestling with adventure
every discovery treasure find rare
materials recipes weapons lore pieces
and beautiful places
change is part of your job
when you die time keeps moving forward
enemies can't stay dead new foes invade
camps that you imagined
10 million lifetime players but richard
can't even break up with you god bless
you
epic
they said lifetime
talk about a 2022 yeah
yeah
next up one of the most
finally comes to the xbox yeah unique
and then my evil twin murdered four of
my husbands because they seem to be in
love with unique
in case that didn't tip you off we're
talking about crusader king's three the
medieval grand strategy role-playing
game
that has you trying to defend your royal
line
from those that would conquer yours
evil twins
into my comfy living room couch
we'll all be rolling for martial
check out crusader kings
so this is the rtx that is coming the
console
yes they
you see
real strategy
requires cunning
there's about a lot of backstabbing back
there
there's a lot of politics
game of thrones
why do they have the characters that big
over the world
it's just to show you where your army is
oh okay okay okay like a representation
that you can zoom in
you really haven't lived until you've
made an eight-year-old the king of
england well it's nice to have hobbies
we've all gotten into something
where's the stuff for me weird like
diving this is all yeah where's my
mental universes projected into a
psychedelic
which means i am so excited for
psychonauts to finally get a sequel it
has been so so long there really is
something special about psychonauts
isn't it there really is indeed
battlefield 2 call of duty 2. they were
great games for sure but they were all
big beefy shooter games
meanwhile psychonauts had humor whimsy
and surprisingly heartfelt moments it
was an oasis of color and humanity in an
era when games were increasingly turning
grimy dark and combative not to mention
having something
for me moments it's my world it's called
why the original is considered a cult
classic it has been a long time coming
and it is finally here enjoy this
long-awaited launch trailer
i tried to go back and play the first
one and i was like no no bobo
and today
is my first day on the job
did you forget everything i taught you
about levitation raspberry
i'm not
supposed to use
and i've got eyes on me
good he can actually get in the water
now all i see is another unruly peasant
oh boy
[Music]
that is
[Music]
[Applause]
complete better package
[Music]
looks better like as far as like
realistic thing but like art style he
thinks this game
might cover it a little bit it might age
better that's high praise
88 on metacritic right now nano okay
[Music]
well it's clear i could not be more
excited for psychonauts too because i
got to be honest me in that original
game we got some beef that needs
settling if you know you know the meat
circus level it is infamous it is brutal
it is difficult to say the least the
final level of the original game that
came out and i cannot believe i'm doing
the math on this one
16 years ago now in game pass tim
schaefer
montgomery i am definitely dating myself
but you all welcome from double flying
productions thank you so much for being
here tim can you believe it it's been 19
years at 19
razz because years story picks up brent
for the first game i love him and even
though it has been a lot of years it's a
game that matters a lot to us i really
love it
and we know that a lot of fans have
meant a lot to them
and we also have a lot of people on the
team here that worked on the first game
as well as bringing on a bunch of new
people like lissette
it's really important for us to carry
the legacy forward especially the cool
style of wonk that is very prevalent in
the first game
style of wonk just put it on a shirt i'm
in there for it uh let's roll it back a
bit of course this can be a kind of a
trippy idea if you're not familiar
psychonauts they still jump into
people's minds i'm assuming like the
first game right so if you're so if a
psychonaut sort of dove into my brain
it'd be like a lot of ted lasso quotes
and french bulldog memes am i correct
tim
yeah that's what's fun about the
psychonauts game is that all the levels
are different just like every person is
different based on their personality if
you could jump into someone's mind what
would it look like in there what would
the what would be the color of the sky
and like who would the monsters be and
and second out you get to do that
because raz has the power of astral
projection and when he goes in he gets
to fight those monsters and help people
deal with their nightmares and wrestle
with their inner demons
and so there's a ton of variety
and there's a lot of anything going on
situations
you know
so we're really focused on
how we can bring forward that style and
wonk and also bring in new levels and
enemies now of course it wouldn't be
psychonauts without new mental demons
and i'm sure it's happening on
psychonauts too what does this mean if
it doesn't mean basically that we're
finally able to slide it inside
right now
relax yourself anxiety uh
and they're definitely here and in
addition to that we also have our doubts
and some new enemies there's our lovely
sensor um also some regrets uh
some flying regrets there are
arrangements
and they definitely are challenging uh
tim why is razz so good at rummaging
through
brains he has some very special skills
he has two whole sets of skills one
being the acrobatic skills he learned
growing up in the circus he can balance
on tightropes jump on trampolines swing
on trapezes and that helps him navigate
and get around to all kinds of
interesting places but he also has this
other side to his personality which is
that he's a powerful psychic so he can
levitate objects he can uh to use
telekinesis and pyrokinesis he has uh
these powers which people might
recognize from the first game as well as
three new powers for the second game he
has the ability to mentally connect
thoughts together and he connect two
thoughts and actually connect two
thoughts together um to solve puzzles
and to navigate in this game uh he has
the power of time bubble which is just
change uh and slow down how things are
moving by changes
[Music]
uh like a companion in battle or this
about the story for a is
because as the original psychonauts we
saw
training to be part of organizations
yeah we have a lot of new characters in
this game we do we have a lot of new
characters in this game um as soon as
raz arrives on the headquarters he
immediately
gets introduced
[Music]
he's no longer the coolest kid in summer
camp
and much to his chagrin
the interns find out that he's the
awkward little child of a circus family
each one of them has their own quirks
and
so a lot of their story gets told in
this game including their backstory and
how it relates to the foundation of the
succulents themselves
well i like that and of course as you
might know already i'm sold but you of
course already knew that when can myself
and the rest of the world exact some
beefy meaty revenge
wow
wow
this stream going left
way yeah catch more of tim shafer and
ask those burning questions about the
newest game in the fan favorite
franchise in our xbox play stream
tomorrow but first we're going from
cleaning out mental cobwebs to good
alien planets in this supremely
satisfying 4k60 trailer for
oh the gunk let's do it all right let's
move forward we had to get out of there
to get out of there
get to this gunk baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
by this game
you didn't want to see more of it though
it looks nice
[Music]
look like a game of the year contender
and i like that we got our little
representation shout out to sis is the
protagonist you know what i'm saying
i like that
gave a bionic arm
bionic
[Applause]
look at six
let's get it a little bit of those 80 90
cartoons we have talked about so many
incredible games today and it's hard to
pick a favorite but let me just say it
is so cool that state of decay 2 is
expanding triple valley come on and hey
you know what oh yeah
thank you i mean talking to yorg is
always a blast and flights him is such a
special game to me because i mean he's
literally letting me travel the world
i was staring daggers of jealousy
watching you talk to tim and lizette
ever at double phone well i will say
this i understand but you got to play
psychonauts 2 already so i don't even
want to hear it
that's true but it's not the same as
talking to the creators just trust me
when i tell you be excited for
psychonauts too i will say this as well
i am excited to see even more of
psychonautical on our xbox
streams we got to get facts yes
news throughout the week at twitch.tv
so make sure to check that out yeah
before kate and i let play around no i'm
sorry well let me just say that it has
been our
pleasure to chat games and nerd out with
everyone today oh it's hands down the
best part of the job for sure
but we're far from done here thank you
guys it's true appreciate your time
and if you're watching our xbox youtube
channel switch over to our xbox
without further ado let's dive in
starting with the new custom for the
horizon this is all this year's stuff
yeah which is available for pre-order
today so players can have a [ __ ]
droning
standard edition of the game we've seen
like nine minutes of this game already
yeah they go they're going home
this year
this game is formless
that's right day and day
jay vardy
we are from marseilles
[Music]
limited edition
[Music]
of force of goodness addict hey charlie
how cool is this
oh my god warlord
what was double fine art director's name
what's her ig
scientific research purpose
absolutely it is feels like it's a part
of the horizon festival like it's just
dropped out of the game into your lap
absolutely absolutely love it and
there's so much we do want to show the
fans and it's been quite difficult to
decide where to start so can you maybe
tell us a bit more about the game mike
sure yeah so forza horizon 5 is bringing
the horizon
breakdown fun and freedom
players are going to set out across the
largest most diverse open world we've
ever built in hundreds of the world's
most beautiful and exciting cars hey
nobody
awesome beautiful historic cities and
even a towering snow-capped volcano the
highest point
in the horizon game so you've talked
about how votes horizon 5 showcases
powerful all-new graphical features but
what more can you tell us about that so
yeah our mexican hdr sky captures really
illuminate the world to the point where
you feel like
yeah
i might have thanks to the xbox series
i see that that's what he's doing to
really make her
another ugly controller uh you'll
encounter the smallest of details as you
travel throughout the world it's not my
fault jabari where's your have been such
an exciting overview what happened in
august
have definitely been with you
that's
oh
for playstation coming out anymore
you're popping off you said this
you know what jabari i get it you you
got abandoned i get it i i know you
write for abandon
you know you got abandoned and
playstation abandoned your whole event
this year
mercedes
it's funny how
the the playstation dude watching the
xbox event god bless
yeah so those differences are exactly
why we chose them mercedes amg i don't
know if that's the first time features
the only thing jabari watching over
there on playstation land is fundamental
and with the 2021 ford bronco
um you know what that's primed for
off-roading
and i'm certain you know what
we're so kind to you that we even gave
you psychonauts
and in typical horizon fashion we are
going to see active volcanoes cars
jumping out of cargo planes and a race
and a beautiful mexicans
all the way to the horizon festival
should we check out i wonder how many
cars they got in grand tourism
here we go here we go you know what
jabari they're going to release another
grand trizmo with director's cut that's
what they're going to do
shout out to
ten dollars to use the controller
with the five house in the chat is it
abandoned playstations whole mantra for
the rest of the year
wow
that's how you drop what is this that's
how you drop into the world jvari they
know this show is weak who did that for
you hey jabari jabari can you do this on
gran turismo japan
what's going on
these flames in this trail is the only
fire you will see all year
[Music]
boy
that's xbox in front of him this slow
ass car
oh my god
okay jay barry says no snow or dirt kick
up where is next gen for next series x
where is anything for playstation at
this time buddy look at that buddy
what
oh my god
you know what happened don't you king
xbox went through the store the
playstation went around that's why we
ain't here
that's that's that's game pass that's
the cooper garage
good
went through a sandstorm yet not one
sand particle on the car demand better
xbox
we'll give it a little bit more juice
for them
yeah i have to devolve this into a messy
decision
look man it's forza we had to do
something man
california oh they about to drop you out
of another bottom of the belly
oh this is it right here
[Music]
let's get it
we have the stunning mercedes amg one at
full speed across mexico
[Music]
right
[Music]
it's a very gorgeous game
that's why like you know i really have a
lot of hopes and things because of that
yeah it's a studio playground because
they said they're using the same engine
didn't you they died
[Music]
this studio might be the best studio
they had like on the rails
[Music]
oh we definitely want to stay tuned for
another forza oh yeah that's good that's
it
yes sir
i told you guys all you guys looking for
oh no halo dudes
gotta talk
[Music]
um oh wait hold on oh is that over well
that was
absolutely
like it was awesome
parachuting
planes anything nice
all the amazing
us right gamepl so for those of you who
just turned up we have just wrapped the
game yeah so now they're showing all the
actors
so much more content to cover so please
sit back and enjoy our latest episode of
horizon 5 let's go live with playground
games we have an excellent show coming
away
so first in case you missed it we're
going to be recapping the major gamescom
announcements from just a few minutes
as well as taking a closer look at the
forza horizon 5 limited edition
need to here's the news
it's the best gaming news site oh
nowhere please go there yes sir
so what we thinking where we at
it's a seven seven yeah seven out of 10.
i mean i am surprised though halo though
no i didn't i i knew it was gonna be no
halo i heard it was supposed to be big
team uh might make a show here but um
all that other stuff now they have their
own legs to stand on and they're gonna
make and create their own thing yeah
that's
the only separate thing no doubt no
doubt attic what you thinking man
seven out of ten i respect them because
they had a lot of their own stuff but
you know it was a good show like i
wouldn't say like it was a boring show
besides like the fours and stuff but the
dying light was curious yeah i mean it
had good announcements but you know at
the end of the day like i feel like the
way that they're building their platform
yeah you know gamescom xo is probably
gonna if they bring back xo that will be
where you'll see more announcements but
yeah when it comes to the gang uh
gamescom tokyo game show the paris show
like if they're at these events it's
literally just going to show you what's
cth doing next what's they did doing
next like i think in terms of big
announcements it's their platforms
they're going to do that on the e3s the
xos the video game awards i think they
really are behind the video game awards
a lot so i think we'll see something
there trying to have a presence there
above the competition would you would
you think
so i was gonna give it a six out of ten
but i have to give it a seven out of ten
because of who say the king's three
coming
because that's a huge announcement and
people need it gave it a seven out of
ten cause we gave it to seven no i gave
this
yeah so
it was it was okay yeah you know it's an
okay show i did what i was supposed to
do some nice announcements
i won feeling what they showed of age
vampires i would have preferred
something else
yeah uh
but it's a day one play anyway yeah that
that was a little out of pocket like
they shouldn't have did that breakdown
history stuff like that
i didn't like
people are doing the the gif on twitter
of the actual thing in the game it's
like this is all we wanted to see like
yeah like they didn't yeah they didn't
show the game of it like i was weird to
be like
this is for everybody else
that's it for me like i was waiting for
the woman
you know i was like oh because i already
knew forza was coming like i wasn't you
know in psychonauts yes it was a this
year joint but i'm hoping jeff keegley
stuff has more for me
i think this was a double down on stuff
that we knew
and uh a refreshing on uh some of the
dlc that they had to get out the door uh
you know um wastelands because they they
made it
out of wastelands and uh to get people
back re-engaged in it um i think they
look at the metrics and the numbers
inside game pass and then they say okay
next up um state of decay right and you
have your uh dlc that's ready to go
uh wastelands okay uh the numbers dipped
on you let's go let's get that up get
that uh reinvigorated get that uh the
crowd going and also pumping up i mean
because force is a huge game right so uh
to end on forza it's nothing wrong with
that that's right i think i'm ending
with that my thing is starting it though
what does that really mean for dying
light like what is what's really
surrounding that title what's going on
with that i want to see uh what what
that really means after the game comes
out and what is it what is it in game
pass yeah what's gonna happen it's weird
because one would think that if the way
they started with dying like that they
were gonna make that announcement like
it was gonna be a game pass or something
like that yeah it was just a shout out
zero files with chat this is the most
legendary stream y'all
we learned how to use trebuchets learned
the legend of rara it topped it off with
what's it good
microsoft's offline simulator obviously
had a multiplayer mode of stuff it was
basically the core stuff that exists
already is getting content
coming out in october
then you had a few sprinkles i was
surprised to see
any mention of like stuff there was like
but there's like two indies that were
like coming out next time
stop huh starting soon
we're starting something straight our
stream
nah it's still not good we good we gotta
we're going right there
you probably have the
um no the destiny yeah we're good we're
good no i said he probably started the
destination yeah the demonstrator yeah
we're good on our drink no i mean i said
i mean the other thing was um
there was a lot of joints missing though
like that but the scorn um bright memory
infinite well those games i honestly
don't believe they're coming out this
year yeah that's what i'm like 20 22.
yeah i was like
because i don't know what we might get
don't see them i don't see those sliding
in any chorus
yup chorus yeah those games you know it
all depends on if they have an xl this
year right
because i feel like if they have an xo
like stuff like that is more closer than
the stuff they show today
so i think they might save that for this
that type of event uh and you gotta
admit there was a lot missing so the
amount that was missing they might have
an xo this year so
now listen
aj empire's bunches like i said they
slapped me that's a huge game for them
again a lot of huge stuff
that i understand getting into the
service is important you know what i'm
saying like i said just
do you think it's big titles only that
needed to
be uh talked about here right now and
that was coming out only one like kind
of threw me off that was next year um
what game was that it they just said oh
hold on domenic and moby said that
bright memory infinite dropped a new ray
tracing trailer today where was that at
the show why didn't drop it at the show
oh
donald talk with the follow-up super
chat it's a four out of ten
wtf was the gunk trailer oh he didn't
like it i waited over a year for more
info and they gave less than what we got
last year yep yeah i'm not gonna lie i
thought they was going to go a little
bit deeper
and um they didn't like they showed some
stuff some different areas or whatever
but they didn't do what i thought they
were going to do with the title and um
that's a little bit disappointing
because i really wanted to see more of
that they could take that whole segment
out of how to craft a little ball and
break a mountain yeah um and and did
more guns
i think i think when it comes to me this
is exactly what i expected so like
it it didn't exceed my expectations
didn't lower them like i mean look we
literally came from the from the uh the
destiny one yeah it's going to be
average i mean
you know i'm not like seven out of ten
that's an average score like yeah it
didn't do anything extravagant it didn't
like beat expectations but considering
the type of e3 they had i can't say
nothing about gamescom shout out to the
legendary hogue law business law firm
love the tone of the show in paris but
no halo is this yeah discomforting i
understand um that is interesting i
thought for sure hope because we watched
the destiny stream
and bungie um to kingston hinted they're
doing a whole halo anniversary 30 years
they showed master chief stuff on a
bungee stream in december so my
prediction was like halo was coming out
in december to coincide with the street
because it was weird i've never seen
bungie kind of acknowledge i got at it
come to the realization mate maybe it
does get pushed back shout out to ran
halo will be tomorrow okay friend ins
inside of randall insider thank you okay
big team mode right rand yeah i was
expecting to see you know if it doesn't
show up tomorrow i need people adding
ryan saying rand was right here's the
question kick
if it doesn't show
[Music]
no
no no it's not it's coming out this year
you know um
that's something that i'm maybe the
backlash from the co-op they made them
delay baby they felt the pressure kick
they felt absolutely zero pressure with
that four percent they felt that he had
to co-op now listen no you know what it
is jabari sent that bag over there
saying i need to win this bet delay this
game what a bag of his knees and you
better send your knees back here boy
don't you give your knees in the way so
if if ryan said tomorrow that means
opening like live then open in line with
jeff keegley so that would make more but
here's the thing though all right let's
break that down because why would you
not show it on your show
i mean
it's just like the the hellblade thing
why wouldn't you show hellblade 2 and
xbox series that's two months before at
the series uh at that
it just seems interesting to me that
they chose marketing wise to do their
own show
and then also do the keegley thing you
know i mean i wonder it was just an
interesting choice not saying it's wrong
it's just interesting i think they know
that
keeley's on the up and up and they're
trying to
give him enough give him
him yeah because they're like look like
maybe if we give you something good for
your show you'll give us some good slot
at the video game award shout out to hey
at least some percentage of the features
could still come out this year
messy shout out to windows central i
believe that's miles xbox wants that
crossover wants to win over non okay i
understand the mentality it just
i could understand it that's the big
show you want to do it but it's just
weird to then still do a show
i don't know maybe just this was the
deep dive for the 2020 halo's not coming
man it's coming
no no no don't don't feed into these
dudes with that narrative before you do
this it's not gonna happen instead of no
all right that's gonna be right you
could be right i mean
miles may be winning me over because
when he says that crossover you want to
win over the non xbox fanbase that's
going to be the major show where you get
more eyes that is not just the xbox fan
so i get that shout out to beanie with
the follow super chat i skipped my nap
for this it could have been an email i
know i got to drag my tired bit of
bitter self to work good day listen man
like the most at most i could give this
is a seven
yeah
i really feel sick energy because i'm
being selfish but the announcements even
though i do not care about age of
whatever and
those are big games so i i gotta say
seven you know what i'm saying yeah i
think seven seven is the most likely at
the end of the day like they showed a
release date for age of empire they
showed brand new content for state of
decay wasteland three uh existing
franchises got dlc so like and to me
like i've never yeah the
gamescom is about the community that's
they've always wanted it it's about
community
and to me i've never seen gamescom as
you drop bombs there
gamescom's always been to me
the communities are going there so you
drop games like like overwatch
seasons and you know i when's the last
time we seen like a giant game be
announced at gamescom i just felt the
pacing still could have been better
we did not need no history channel of
triple shades and stuff like that and
then listen it wasn't awful pacing all
the way throughout there were moments
they would go on bang bang bang and they
were doing whatever but there were
moments there was too many two times on
screen and stuff like that but you know
it's just a different approach you know
what it is it's a different approach to
games come from them that i'm not used
to
i'm used to them
kind of throwing out more of their
bigger announcements as well as you know
a little bit of stuff was coming i
thought it was a solid show and maybe
because like i i like wasteland i like
state of decay right i'm not the biggest
fan of rare but at least you know they
did get like
uh borderlands with the rare collab that
that's that's big like then they show
the the x cloud coming to last gen
console so that's like look like you
know we're going to still give those
opportunities i mean that's good
if anything i've seen i've seen them do
that that's like look we're moving on
if anything when they announced that uh
you know xbox uh xcloud going to
consoles the 8th gen that showed to me
we're moving on yeah i forgot about that
that was a big announcement i have to
forget i forgot about the con xbox cloud
gaming coming to console
was a big announcement for the older gen
the base consoles to be able to play
that that that's in the fact that it's
ready and ultimate that was big shout
out the flamethrower chat why did gunk
get less time than a controller um
um neo wise uh canadian he said witch
queen expansion and wasteland three dlc
have to pay yes you got to pay
let me tell them oh i don't know about
witch queen just yet we'll see because
bungie they're gonna do a thing with
bungie it seems right they said on a
specific day so i'm not sure whether to
give you that they might give a release
taper for
halo tomorrow
they're saying that's going on game pass
is definitely up in the air yeah let me
give them a reason why they gave you
more time on on on the controller than
they did for gunk the controller's not
in game pass
yeah yeah i got that goodbye that
i feel that i mean though those
controllers sell like hotcakes
i don't think they need me right now
just so like all that all all they have
to do is go on twitter
and just show a picture like a five
second gif of it and they're good like
listen i can't wait to get the halo one
that's coming out this year alongside
the game you know so uh you guys tune in
for that um
i can't wait to get the the shea butter
greased up knees yeah from jay martin my
way from jay yo jay i would like to know
when you're coming on the show right
you're going to come on the announcement
or you're going to come on the release
we try to schedule the better we need
you we need you in a matter of fact just
let us he's going to delete his face his
twitter he's going to delete his twitter
no i want that camera make sure your
camera clean bruh
no none of that tcl camera stuff bro
anyway that's pretty much all i got oh
as far as all beijing he said haven't
gotten into destiny is it too late to
jump in not too late now you see that
yeah but bungie definitely won the day
there's no question bungee stream was
was insane it was crazy this is that gal
yeah everything about bungie stream was
nostalgic
[Applause]
that on twitter which queen you have to
pay even if it's on game pass
interesting oh don't don't matter i've
always lied and
no it's not
no it don't no it don't because on a
joint they have like a premium um season
pass and they have a regular joint you
know how it goes if you get in on the
the premium season pass then you have
all the top tier stuff if you don't then
you have bottom someone find it i want
to see it for sure i want to get that
before i leave if uh game pass if you
got if they said anything in reference
to which queen that would be didn't it
drop today
um well the new season or season of the
loss drop today but they announce which
queen that will drop later game pass
which queen let's see if no i got a
whole season i gotta get started right
now oh no it is yeah yeah yeah yeah it
says yeah bob don plays uh part of the
fact says which queen will not be
available in gamepad so we do we gonna
have to pay that that's the
deal well i guess my prediction was
wrong yeah it is what it looks like
all right no doubt but anyway that's
what i got let's get these outros up out
of here def singer man good to have you
back in the realm you did the marathon
with us bungie stream
xcom
xbox
you know what i'm saying where can i
find people find you what you got going
on sir
well shout out to the lord for having me
through it was a great the destiny
stream was the highlight of the day here
literally everywhere the same way it's
spelt um
and yeah
no doubt no doubt salute salute and of
course lord addict the wolf what's going
on man
you can catch me on twitter at lord
addicts iop you can catch me on youtube
at gaming addict keep in mind we have
reached our uh quote for the chivalry
stream so we'll be starting to set that
up in the next couple weeks nice i
appreciate everyone coming through we
had up to like 400 people yeah yeah i
really appreciate the people that was at
the destiny one two yeah a lot of
non-destiny fans about that one too so
that was dope no doubt lord king pulling
up for the xbox stream we're gonna find
people find you what you got going on
sir
uh i had to get my rest for that dusty
joint um i didn't want my joints spoiled
sorry yeah what is with you not watching
streams of reveals though of destiny
you know cause i love that game like
that so you know it all like getting
that nah i got that i got the season to
start the day i'm gonna talk you realize
the witch queens in like four months
exactly right you're gonna you gotta
avoid it for four months
i know i'm gonna have fun right now
talking to my friends i'm gonna have fun
right now i need to sleep and i need
energy okay i can't i can't come to the
microsoft joint with low energy i gotta
have high energy so i had to pick one of
the two i couldn't do both okay you know
i'm up at 12 o'clock at night working
all night till the morning so
i respect you guys so i got to give you
that energy and i know congress gonna
give you our energy regardless to what
anything does to me so i know my bro had
that on a lot you know so um
and then that's i saw everybody else was
this y'all did a good job thank you um
but for me you can catch me on uh legion
of doom friday nights uh that's the
rebranding of uh
uh dcx open mic uh so we had a inaugural
show
and um
we saw darth maul in the back make his
debut fire no we got a kos going up with
the lizard as you may see the lizard has
made his way back into the red room
along with uh spiderman and his amazing
friends
y'all gonna get a chance to see the red
room when i do the kos with dolph maul
it's going to be absolutely nuts it's
going to be incredible you can find me
on twitter at king david otw where i
have such a good time i had such a great
time today with a couple of good old
friends of mine absolutely who happened
to pop their head out of the dirt every
time they think that i'm fit to die and
i have to show them i have the strength
to battle them back to the controls so
you know yeah i could get messy and i
don't but you know i just had to you
know slay a few dudes today and you can
catch me on uh lords of gaming.net whoa
you guys don't know about that
is the best
gaming news site that is on the web and
if you haven't been there i'm gonna tell
you to go there you won't go no place
else go check it out really go seriously
don't know on garden numbers go check it
out because if if you're looking at any
of these shows we go to these shows uh
play nyc uh footage is there
no other gaming news site has that stuff
period
he ain't lying about that part
about that buzz i gotta salute let's
lose everybody again soon everybody
coming through good to see y'all pulling
up last minute stream the double duty me
and i got some work to do so we're gonna
cut up out of here soon but i appreciate
it these guys are working hard a lot of
stuff going on it's tuned out for the
last word it's going to be crazy this
week obviously king
that dcx this week but what's the date
what's the official
legion legion of doom check about
support statue community what's going on
i know no attic show this week because
obviously we were doing this you know i
said so unless you got something else
scheduled with attic show
no not yet
we're just doing three shows in one day
that's too much yeah so that and then
you already know the realm on sunday
salute also packs hurt yeah you know
this is a lot also patreon members um we
got that roundtable stream you know what
i'm saying what time last word this week
it might be
seven p.m but don't quote me it might be
7 p.m
everybody be seven we got i got to
confirm with the guests i think we got
teddy in the realm but i will let you
know what's going on anyway that's what
i got
hit that like button
if it gets to 300 singer will sing for
us get into 300. oh my god no no i won't
but i forgot you can
[Music]
the building also they were in the
destiny stream with us you know they
shout out the forte shout out
we're about to hear that soothing voice
coming from you right now you could just
got her conqueror uh sale yeah shout out
to luke again that conqueror is just
shout out to iron laws podcast destiny
it was literally a whole clan industry
six more that's it
he tried it you gotta hear that soothing
death singer voice it is i'll i'll do
paper
anyway
yo